Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Ce qui me chiffonne depuis que j'ai
commencé ma carrière dans le conseil,
c’est qu’on ne prête
quasiment jamais attention
au lien primordial qui existe
entre le corps et le travail.
Depuis l'aube des temps, l'homme a mis
toute son intelligence et toute sa force
au service d’un but unique :
prolonger et améliorer les capacités
de son corps et de son esprit.
Toutes les grandes inventions humaines,
comme le feu, la roue,
l’écriture, le moteur
et le circuit imprimé
nous ont permis de nous affranchir des
limites d’action imposées par notre corps
et de passer d’une ère à une autre.
En maîtrisant le feu,
nous avons pallié
la faiblesse de notre constitution
et fini par ne plus craindre
aucun prédateur.
Avec la roue et le moteur,
nous avons décuplé notre force.
Un seul homme peut faire avancer un train
là où il en fallait mille pour tracter
la même charge beaucoup plus lentement.
Sur le plan des idées,
l’écriture nous a permis
de transmettre des informations
au-delà de la portée naturelle
de notre voix
et de les conserver au-delà
des limites de notre mémoire.
Et enfin, le numérique est
en passe de nous permettre
de nous affranchir des barrières
du temps et de l’espace.
Demain, nous pourrons échanger
avec n’importe qui, faire n’importe quoi,
depuis n'importe quel endroit du monde.
Au fil des siècles,
nous avons si bien travaillé
que le corps est devenu
de moins en moins nécessaire
à l’accomplissement
des tâches utiles pour la société.
Hier, le chef du groupe,
c’était l’homme le plus fort physiquement.
Aujourd’hui, la force, nous ne l’admirons
plus que dans les sports,
donc dans un contexte de divertissement,
mais plus de lutte.
Et la plupart des affrontements entre
nations ne sont plus des conflits armés,
mais bien des guerres de l'information.
Pour vous le dire autrement,
David a définitivement remporté
son combat contre Goliath.
À tel point qu’aujourd’hui,
le travail manuel
est généralement déconsidéré
par rapport au travail intellectuel.
Dans cette salle, nous travaillons
presque tous avec un ordinateur
et nous n’avons pas besoin de savoir
courir vite ni d’être endurant à l’effort
pour réussir nos carrières.
Appartenir à l'élite, c'est ne plus avoir
à se servir de son corps pour travailler.
On l’observe
dans les mœurs professionnelles,
et notamment les mœurs qui sont liées
à l’utilisation des espaces de travail.
Nous sommes passés d’un monde
où notre place dans la hiérarchie
se traduisait physiquement
à un monde où on cherche
exactement le contraire.
Avant les années 2000, la plupart
des employés avaient un bureau
et la taille et l’agrément de ce bureau
étaient directement associés
à leur place dans la hiérarchie.
Un meilleur poste,
c’était synonyme de plus de place,
plus de confort, plus d’intimité.
Aujourd’hui, c’est le triomphe
de l’open space,
un concept séduisant -
il paraît que ça facilite
la communication entre les équipes.
Mais c’est séduisant
surtout pour les investisseurs
à qui il permet de réaliser
des économies substantielles.
Il est évidemment plus coûteux
de réserver un espace par personne
que de mettre tout le monde
dans le même bureau.
Mais l’open space a déjà montré
ses limites de rentabilité.
Si, comme moi,
vous avez travaillé en open space,
vous avez dû observer
ces comportements si typiques
qu’il nous est impossible
de les attribuer au hasard.
Les travailleurs des open spaces,
ils portent plus souvent un casque,
ils envoient davantage d’emails
et ils vont même jusqu’à avancer
leur heure d’arrivée au bureau
dans l’espoir de dégotter
les meilleures places,
c’est-à-dire les places les plus isolées.
Par notre comportement,
nous recréons les barrières
qu'étaient les murs et les portes.
Plus nous ouvrons les espaces,
moins nous communiquons.
Et cette dégradation de la communication
par les moyens mêmes
qui sont supposés l’augmenter
se retrouve dans l’usage
de la visio-conférence -
visio-conférence qui est devenue si banale
après quelques mois de confinement.
J’ai participé à des centaines
de visio-conférences,
et le passage de la 3D à la 2D,
la retransmission de la chair en pixels,
détruit une grande partie des informations
que nous partageons en communiquant.
Au-dessous des épaules,
il ne nous est pas possible
de voir les gestes
qui pourraient traduire l’inconfort
ou l’agitation de notre interlocuteur,
comme les mains qui tremblent
ou la jambe impatiente.
Et si le cadrage est plus serré,
on ne voit pas l’axe entre la tête
et le corps, autrement dit la posture.
On ne voit pas notre interlocuteur
rougir ou pâlir.
On ne le voit pas transpirer.
En fait, en limitant
la perception de nos sens,
la visio bloque des processus
cognitifs fondamentaux
et notamment l’action
des neurones miroirs,
les neurones miroirs sur lesquels repose
l’un de nos plus formidables talents :
l’empathie.
Et si, comme on le dit aujourd’hui,
l’empathie est à la base
de notre intelligence,
eh bien, on peut se demander
si la visio ne nous rend pas stupides.
Le corps, ce n’est pas seulement
une limite péjorative.
Deux personnes ne communiquent jamais de
la même manière face à face ou à distance.
Elles ne communiquent jamais de la même
manière si elles sont libres de le faire
ou si elles y sont forcées
par l'absence de cloison.
Je ne suis pas en train de vous dire
qu’il faut renoncer à tous ces nouveaux
moyens de communication.
Je suis en train de vous dire
que plus on utilise un moyen puissant
pour amplifier la portée d’un message,
plus ce message est distordu.
Et cette distorsion,
si elle est trop grande,
elle finit par rendre
le message inintelligible.
Donc, cette économie de court terme -
s’épargner les transports pour préférer
faire des visio à la maison,
supprimer les murs -
ces économies de court terme masquent
un manque de rentabilité à long terme.
Il est urgent pour nous de partir à la
reconquête d'un écosystème de travail
dans lequel nous parviendrons
à un équilibre harmonieux
entre les audaces permises
par les nouvelles technologies
et les lois immuables de la nature.
L’une de ces lois fondamentales, c’est
que le contexte influence les personnes.
Imaginez-vous travailler
dans un palais du 16e siècle à Florence.
dans un préfabriqué en tôle à Nanterre.
Vous ne ferez pas
la même expérience de votre travail
et donc vous ne produirez pas
le même travail.
Pensez aux rituels des écrivains :
là où l’un cherchera l’inspiration
d’un café bruyant bondé,
un autre préférera être isolé
avec des boules Quiès dans les oreilles.
Prenons l'exemple de Flaubert.
Flaubert avait chez lui un gueuloir.
C’était une pièce dédiée dans laquelle,
littéralement, il gueulait ses textes
pour en estimer l’impact,
la portée mot à mot.
Est-ce que Flaubert aurait produit
les mêmes œuvres
s’il avait travaillé
au milieu d’un open space ?
Est-ce que Newton aurait eu
l’éclair de génie
qui lui a fait révolutionner la physique
s’il n’y avait pas eu la peste de Londres
qui l’a contraint à passer cinq ans
seul à la campagne ?
Et si ces génies ont besoin
de ce cadre d’excellence
pour exprimer le meilleur de leur talent,
il est bien naïf de croire,
bien orgueilleux de penser,
qu’il en va différemment
pour le commun des mortels.
Et pourtant,
le cadre qu’on nous promet pour l’avenir,
le cadre de travail,
c’est un univers numérique standardisé,
à l’image du métavers qui a été récemment
annoncé par Mark Zuckerberg.
Quelle sera la place du corps
dans ce nouveau monde ?
L’enjeu des siècles à venir,
qui a été précipité par nos
choix politiques face au Covid,
c’est de déterminer quelle place
nous laissons au corps
dans la définition
de ce qu’est un être humain.
Et si ce que je vous dis vous semble
être de la science-fiction,
considérez ce paradoxe
que constituent d’un côté
les influenceuses qui utilisent
tous les moyens techniques possibles
pour ressembler aux standards
des héroïnes de jeux vidéo, du manga,
et, de l’autre côté,
à ces influenceuses numériques
qui comptabilisent déjà
des millions de followers
et qui imitent toujours plus fidèlement
l’apparence humaine.
D’un côté,
des hommes qui veulent ressembler
à des robots,
de l’autre, des robots qui veulent
ressembler à des hommes.
L’horizon dans lequel l’homme
et la machine vont se rencontrer
est très proche.
Et si la machine supplée tous nos efforts,
si le corps n’est plus qu’une image
qu’on peut modifier à l’envi, à l’infini,
quel sera l’impact de ces changements
sur notre esprit
et sur notre rapport au travail ?
Si [David] a remporté
son combat contre Goliath,
il est urgent pour nous de veiller
à ce que David ne devienne pas Midas.
Car pour ce roi légendaire, c’est
la perspective d’une richesse infinie
qui s’est avérée être la cause
de sa pauvreté absolue.
Et comme pour Midas, l’homme du 21e
siècle pourrait bien perdre son humanité
au moment même où il pense
s’en être saisi dans son intégralité.
Je vous remercie de votre écoute,
les oreilles grandes ouvertes.
(Applaudissements)